Hunter Biden who I have not hammered on
this show I know some right-wing hosts
they talk about Hunter Biden all the
time most of his Shenanigans I think are
not all that interesting they're just
sort of depraved and gross and sad but
these really are interesting the man is
the poster child for the corrupt Elite
and he's committed all sorts of crimes
in virtually every genre I think and he
gets off without so much as really even
a slap on the wrist he'll get maybe some
probation for the tax misdemeanors and
then he goes into a diversion program
for his gun charge but I think Jenna
Ellis found this still on the doj
website
it would appear that Hunter Biden is not
even eligible for this diversion program
which is a way to avoid jail time and
eventually have the gun charge expunged
from his record because the doj says
absent approval by the office of the
Deputy attorney general any pre-trial
diversion program created by a U.S
attorney's Office shall exclude any
individual who is
accused of an offense related to child
pornography accused of an offense
related to Serious bodily injury or
death and then here's number three
accused of an offense involving
brandishing or use of a firearm or other
deadly weapon
we can see we have photographs of Hunter
Biden brandishing his weapon
so
they're they're probably at the doj
they're going to try to to be really
really uh specific about the definition
of brandishing to exclude whatever
Hunter did
or they're just going to ignore it like
like our prosecutors do so often now
when it involves politically favored
people and groups they're going to say
okay never mind now one of the
criticisms of this corrupt Elite ruling
class and the way that Hunter Biden is
just getting off with a ton of crimes no
big deal is it gonna say well you know
the lower class never gets off with
these kinds of crimes oh it's those rich
politically connected people they get
away with murder but the the poor people
on the street they never get away with
anything and that's not exactly true
these diversion programs are largely for
lower class people on the street with
all sorts of records and all sorts of
bad neighborhoods plenty of Street
criminals and gangsters get these exact
deals
I mean this is the whole point of the
Soros prosecutors
the the
leftist installed prosecutors who get
into their jobs and they stop
Prosecuting Street crime because they'll
say well if we prosecute certain crimes
it's more likely to
involve black people and that would be
racist and for racial Equity we're going
to let gangsters look back onto the
street we're going to pre-trial
diversion programs and we're going to
give them you know Bond and we're going
to let them off on probation and all the
rest of it they go commit more crimes
the distinction here with the corruption
of the doj and the prosecutors more
generally is not that it's the rich get
one set of rules and the poor get
another set of rules Donald Trump's
pretty rich and they're going to try to
throw them in prison for the rest of his
life because he kept his own
presidential documents for a little bit
because he committed crimes that all of
us spread crimes that all of his
predecessors committed and that
Democrats who never even were president
have committed
no it's not a it's not a rich versus
poor thing it's just a politically
favored versus politically disfavored
thing if you are
a black street criminal in a Democrat
City
you are more likely to get off the hook
for crimes you'll be put in one of these
programs and if you are the degenerate
first son the son of the president who
commits all sorts of crimes you're more
likely to get off too and if you're a
conservative and if you threaten the
ruling class
whether you're poor whether you're in
the middle whether you're rich they're
going to throw the book at you
you could be a poor deplorable hillbilly
irredeemable white guy from the from the
red States you could be a Midwestern
granny who was taking some photos in the
capital rotunda on January 6th the worst
day in history or you could be a
billionaire president of the United
States doesn't matter if you oppose the
ruling class that's when they go after
you right now go to puretalk.com Knowles
a company I'm proud to stand behind and
that is proud to stand behind us and our
country is pure talk veteran owned with
a 100 American Workforce they share our
beliefs that is why Pure Talk is the
official cell phone wireless partner of
the daily wire but that's not the only
reason your talk also happens to be the
most Dependable 5G Network in the U.S
they're a top tier provider at a
fraction of the cost of other woke
companies you know which ones I'm
talking about ATT Verizon T-Mobile
companies that don't care about you or
your beliefs mix and match your plans to
fit every person in your family
choose from talk text in 5G data for
just 20 a month all the way up to
unlimited data with the mobile hotspot
for 55 a month you vote with how you
spend your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that do not support
you go to puretalk.com Knowles you'll
get great coverage and save while you're
doing it go to puretalk.com Knowles you
will save an additional fifty five zero
percent off your first month because
they value EU go to puretalk.com
wireless for Americans by Americans
right now head on over to hillsdale.edu
Knowles are you a few years or maybe
decades out of school and wondering what
the heck did I even learn and what was
the point you might think to yourself
that you don't have the time to learn
something new if that's you know this
you're not alone it's not too late since
1844 Hillsdale College has been
providing education and Faith freedom
and character they've taken some of the
core classes they teach on campus and
made them available for free online for
anyone who wants to learn that is right
for free there are 39 free courses to
choose from ranging from the U.S
Constitution the Book of Genesis the
free market and much more they are easy
to follow they're self-paced so you can
start whenever you want in fact you can
start right now it's everything you need
all in one place with no long-term
commitment let Hillsdale College be your
guide learn when and where you want go
to hillsdale.edu Knowles to enroll no
cost it's easy to get started
hillsdale.edu Knowles Canada w-l-e-s
hillsdale.edu Knowles
last thing with Hunter there's another
story out
as I've said I don't really like to dig
in too much to all of his personal Saucy
disgusting scandals because
they're just Audrey and they don't shed
much light on things this one does
though Hunter Biden was a member of an
elite La sex club called sanctum sanctum
it's just like all businesses that were
started around 2012 and 2013 all these
Millennial businesses from you know
Consulting startups to sex dungeons
apparently they took the vowels out so
it's snctm
uh it's a private members Club
that prioritizes the safety and privacy
of their esteemed members above all and
it involves a ton of Hollywood
celebrities and big people in the news
media and
I won't I won't name the names but
they're you can read about them they're
really very prominent famous people and
apparently the club was founded
after the movie Eyes Wide Shut came out
so it's not just that eyes wide shot
parties really exist remember Madison
cauthor and the Republican Congressman
mentioned that there were Eyes Wide Shut
parties in DC and then he was
immediately just ejected from Congress
well well it turns out the eyes wide
show parties they happen in Hollywood
they're really involve very wealthy
famous people and they're consciously
eyes wide shop parties they're based on
the movie eyes wide shot so anyway the
club cost 75 grand a year to become a
member and includes actors rock stars
CEOs even City officials according to
the LA Times and Hunter Biden was a
member of this club
what's most striking about the existence
of this club is not that it involved
Hunter Biden if something is degenerate
in America over the last 15 years
there's a good bet that Hunter Biden was
involved in it
what's striking about this club is that
it's no different
from
activities that have taken place since
the dawn of human history among depraved
Elite esoteric
immoral people it's been going on
forever just after I read the piece
about the elite La eyes wide shot sex
club I read a piece about an ancient
Egyptian cult that got high on
psychedelics and drank bodily fluid
cocktails
this is just a story I think it was on
The Drudge Report 25 year old 2500 year
old ancient Egyptian cult used to get
high on psychedelics drink fluid from
places that they shouldn't drink it from
and also also had all sorts of alcoholic
drinks and drugs and archaic vas from
the era resembling the deity Bez who is
some Demon that the ancient Egyptians
worshiped of fertility and War showed
traces of psychoactive substances the
cult members who took the drug would
experience delirium hallucinations and
heightened libido they would use this to
trip during their religious ceremonies
and the religious ceremonies would
involve orgies would involve all sorts
of orgies and
weird gross activities this is the same
thing as the LA Eyes Wide Shut sex club
the LA sex club is called sanctum
sanctum meaning holy coming from the
word to consecrate
the LX sex club I guarantee you involved
a lot of alcohol and drugs
so
and then
it involved a lot of weird ideas about
what a human being is and how we relate
to one another and and what is sacred
it's not just that these guys were
getting their jollies by bumping uglies
in some weird dungeon in Los Angeles
they considered this to be holy the way
that our society talks about pride month
and all the weird sexual rituals
involved with pride they speak about it
as though it is Holy as though it is
virtuous as though it is a kind of
religion because it is it's it's the
same old kinds of Cults it's the same
old kinds of demon worshiping Cults that
we've had since 3000 years ago in
ancient Egypt
and people
often don't realize when they're an
occult people often don't realize when
they're engaging in religious rituals I
bet a lot of the guys at that sex club
they just think they're having a fun
time and they're cool and they're modern
and they don't believe in anything man
they're doing the exact same thing
as an ancient Egyptian called
consciously worshiping demons can't get
away from it human nature just just
Remains the Same boy what a great clip
that was make sure that you ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time